what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I'm gonna call it now uh baby
Groot is going to steal the show and
Guardians - I'm so excited for that
movie I'm so hyped we get to see ego the
Living Planet I don't know if he'll be
an actual planet like I'm hoping they
don't do something off the wall
something bonkers I'm hoping that
doesn't happen but I have faith in James
Gunn um hopefully we'll see the
Celestials again which I'm kind of
excited about I hope we see like like
the celestial the one above all not the
one above all one above all God in the
Marvel Universe but there is a celestial
call the one above all they're two
different beings look what we see like
like Ashima to judge like that would be
kind of cool like the Celestials are
pretty awesome in terms of how they look
well I think we saw a scene with the
judge in guardians one uh the the
celestial that obliterated the entirety
of a planet using the power gym which is
kind of weird the Celestials were never
needed to use power stones to do
anything like or everybody needed to use
Infinity stones to do anything they were
just these godlike beings that have an
insane amount of power but regardless I
think that um that baby Groot is going
to steal the show so we are covering
Brian Michael Bendis is guardians of the
galaxy now this is a perfect example of
how Bendis basically takes over a title
and then makes it his own and really
just kind of forgoes all previously
existing continuity now under normal
circumstances this wouldn't really
matter and it doesn't really matter for
it for Peter quill much of his past
continuity is still intact with the
exception of everything before
annihilation and the reason why is
because of the fact that when Steve
Englehart originally made star-lord
originally introduced Peter quill his
goal was to give us this very star
trek-like scenario in the sense that
Peter quill basically attained the
mantle of star-lord after having it
bestowed upon him by an old man it was
very much like you know Shazam let us
say the wizard Shazam gave Billy Batson
the power to say the word Shazam and
become the superhero that we know is
Captain Marvel wishes and depending on
what era of comic books you're looking
at but the fact remains here that that
was the original view and star Lords
role which is basically just kind of
traverse the space waste the problem was
that at the time really going up until
2006 with annihilation Marvel's cosmic
landscape was just kind of totally
disconnected I mean that's why
annihilation is such a huge story
because it began the process by Dan
Abbott to consolidate all these
different aspects of cosmic characters
Captain Marvel plays are all these
different guys and bring them all
together and to say here's what's
officially part of the Marvel cosmology
and here are the crazy things that are
going on in space
because of that prior to annihilation
star-lord just kind of existed out in
left-field he was just out there in his
own line of stories and almost never
really I don't think he ever crossed
over with anybody in the main Marvel
Universe now the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that in 2000 with
Inhumans volume 3 Rafael Marin and and
Jose Ladon I think it was wanted to
basically bring star-lord into the main
Marvel continuity and in their mind the
way to do that was to create a guy named
Jason of Spartak so of course he was
young he was brash he was very similar
to Peter quill in terms of what he was
like when he was younger but because of
a whole big coup that was going on you
know during the marriage of a Shiar and
the smart toy really really to worry
about all that the fact remains that he
was basically banished from his planet
he was deemed not fit to rule as the
Prince of sparked acts destined to be
Emperor he simply wasn't ready for the
crown so his father basically kicked him
out now this is basically a huge source
of contention and the reason why is
because of the fact that up until this
story that version of Jason of smart axe
was the father of Peter quill that was
the way it had always been established
that's the way it was generally accepted
bindus came in and basically said nope
he co-opted the entirety of the
guardians of the galaxy mythos and said
no no no there's a guy named Jason of
Sparta taxes spelled entirely different
he's an emperor and he is the father of
Peter quill so traditional fans of Jason
he'll really know if there are any but
traditional fans of Jason as far attacks
hated it they absolutely hated the idea
that that Jason as far attacks was being
co-opted and basically being changed up
but for a majority of the comic-book
landscape they didn't really care just
because of the fact that if they were
interested in star-lord it was all post
annihilation it was all you know the
star-lord solo series and different
things like that the Reformation of the
guardians of the galaxy or really the
the formation of the guardians of the
galaxy after annihilation conquest
that's all they really cared about and
so what they got here just fit in it
just made sense to them and so what we
initially do here is we pick up with
basically guardians of the galaxy zero
point one and the reason why is because
the fact that Marvel almost never does
zero issues zero issues were something
that were established by Valiant Comics
in the 1990s and then used by DC
following that and zero issues are
basically just origins nine times out of
ten zero issues are here's where it all
begins
Secret Wars number zero initiate the
secret war storyline secret Empire
number zero initiates the secret Empire
storyline itself can
kein but it basically sets the stage for
everything that's going to come after
that's why DC basically did zero month
when they launched the new 52 it was new
origins for all the characters in DC
Comics and so because of that this
basically joins up with a woman named
Meredith quill and the arrival of Jason
now again we don't really know why he's
here we don't know how he got here we
simply just know that he's here so we're
just kind of left to believe something
went wrong he was in a battle or
skirmish or something along those lines
you can really inject any reason that
you want to but the fact remains is that
he's here now the funny thing about this
is that he's almost immediately tended
to and nursed back to health by Meredith
but Meredith's reaction is one of like
hey I'm taking safety precautions I've
got an elephant gun pointed at your head
if you do something wrong your head
won't be there anymore so it's kind of
funny to see her reaction because it's
very much the same reaction we would
have I'll go ahead and say it Jason of
Spartak is a stud he's a good-looking
guy but even then like it's like hey
look I don't know if you're just like a
weird-looking alien this looks like
masquerading as a human but just kind of
wanted to see these scenarios that's one
of the reasons why I love Bendis writing
when it comes to characters because he's
so good at making characters like real
and tangible in terms of how they talk
and how they you know how they mingle
with one another and so on and so forth
but you know from here we basically
learned that over the course of Jason's
time on earth his ultimate goal was to
repair his ship and then return back to
smart acts taking up his role as the
Emperor but the idea was that the longer
he and Meredith spent together the more
they fell in love and so again this is
really kind of cool because for those of
you guys who saw guardians of the galaxy
one and then immediately took to the
Internet and we're looking up you know
like who is Peter Quill's father this is
why people were saying it's JSON of
spartax because this is what Brian
Michael Bendis established in his comic
it was relatively new by the time that
guardians of the galaxy came out but in
fact remains that this is established
information in Marvel Comics so this is
really the origin we're kind of talking
about here but the result is that of
course the Jason and Meredith end up
sharing you know moments of one another
which results in Meredith becoming
pregnant now the interesting thing about
this is that with Jason his duty is to
his empire first and to everything else
second and this is kind of cool because
it's basically been just saying heavy is
the crown and this is one of reasons why
I like this as well is because we're
able to relate to this right I mean none
of us are emperors at least I'm not an
emperor and if you're if you're the guy
from Nigeria that keeps telling me that
you're the pro
Emperor and all I have to do is send you
money please stop doing that no one
believes you
alright the fact remains here with Jason
is it's really this idea that we all
make sacrifices right like we all have
to sacrifice the things we want for duty
honor for the things that we need or the
things that are required from us just
due to some measure of responsibility
case in point there's a vacation you've
been planning forever and ever and ever
and then you start a new job and that
vacation falls within your probationary
period you'll have to cancel your
vacation for the sake of being able to
uphold the responsibilities of that job
and so again while you know while
doesn't necessarily compare to like
being an emperor the fact remains it
still creates kind of an interesting
scenario in terms of how Bendis gives us
these characters and how they relate to
one another so a Chloe Jason's departure
following you know him basically leaving
meredith ends up finding out that she's
pregnant so what we do is we jump
forward by about 10 years now the waited
Bendis mesa Coleco ops this origin is
really kind of cool the reason why is
because of the fact that we really end
up seeing this version of Peter that's
vastly different from the one that we're
used to which is to say that the Peter
when he first popped up was very spoiled
he was very arrogant he believed he was
destined to become an astronaut and the
reason why was of course because of the
fact that his mother had been killed by
aliens now of course this story will
basically switch that over to the badoon
which are like these he's worn this
warning race that's really really good
at making weapons and ships but the fact
remains that Peter is very young he's
very brash but he's also very much of
the mindset that those who can't stand
up for themselves deserve to have
somebody stand up for them until those
individuals can stand up for themselves
basically you what do the right thing
even if it means that you just get the
hell beat out of you in the process now
of course this really manifests itself
in the form of some guy who is just
picking on a younger girl because of her
own heritage and so because of that
Peter of course stands up to him and
beats the absolute hell out of them and
for the first time in his life
presumably this kid is introduced to
consequences to the fact that bad things
happen to you when you are a dick and so
because of that it's very much this this
traditional origin of Peter being played
in by Bendis so because of the fact that
the death of Peter Quill's mother at the
hands of aliens who have landed on earth
is an inherent part of what makes him
who he is now the motivation behind
these aliens has changed over the years
but the idea of Peter's mom being killed
by aliens always stays the same it's the
basis for why he goes out into space in
the first place and so what happens in
this story is essentially that double do
now
again this race of warring aliens that
are really good at making weapons and
ships uh they end up coming to the
realization that JSON of spartax had
stopped on earth somewhere along the
line and he had continued his own
lineage and so the idea was to kill
meredith and kill peter now we don't
know why all we know is that they just
intend to kill jason's line now of
course this basically leads to Peter
quill blowing him to pieces with an
elephant gun but the fact remains here
that Peter actually ends up a taining
his father's elemental gun and so again
this really sets the stage for a lot of
what we know with regards to with
regards to star-lord with regards to
Peter grill being the character that
we're familiar with and so what we end
up finding out is this entire story is
being told by Peter quill to Tony Stark
to iron man who is officially joining
the guardians of the galaxy now the
reason why iron man's joining the
guardians of the galaxy really comes out
of it comes out a civil war to be honest
and it was just a long-running series of
stories Civil War post-civil war the
initiative iron man becoming director of
shield but all this really seemed to
come to a head in mad fractions insanely
amazing run of iron man which is
basically the long way down storyline
and it was so good like lightmap
fractions iron man curing Guillen's iron
man I tell people all the time those are
like some of the best stories which
really kind of have their roots and
Warren Ellis's Iron Man extremists which
in and of itself is an amazing sort all
the Iron Man stories really after Civil
War were insane just because the fact
that Iron Man was so popular post-civil
war and the Iron Man movie had just come
out so because of that Marvel was like
we're going to make anybody the super
popular character we're going to make an
Iron Man
so again it was really cool to see a lot
of those stories unfold but what this
does is it brings Peter quill not going
to contact with his father Jason now
again the funny thing about this the
interaction between the two is that in a
lot of ways Jason looks at his son as a
disappointment not in the sense that
he's failed in his entirety but in the
sense that Peters not living up to his
full potential and he's not maintaining
what it is that he should be doing in
terms of establishing himself as a
legitimate heir to the throne of
spartaxian it's really one of those
things where it's like how you conduct
reflects on me and you're making me look
that this really is really what it is is
happening here now again this is really
just the two of them bumping heads but
ultimately Jason basically says the rule
that's been established now is that the
earth is often limits of course we're
basically given this idea of the
intergalactic council so the supreme
intelligence this sort of religious /
a political leader of the Kree Empire
this also basically just an amalgamation
of all the different Kree the smartest
created have ever existed over the
course of the entire crew races history
we have in of course the brood we have
the Badoon we have a gladiator who's
currently running the Shiar empire the
fact remains here that went earth being
off-limits Peter's response here is look
if you tell people that Earth is off
limits and that there'll be no measure
of protection for it from anybody no
one's allowed to go there then that
means that only bad guys will go there
it's like it's like the gun effect right
you know if you outlaw guns then the
only ones will have them are criminals
and so if you turn around and say nobody
can have you know nobody can can go to
earth then only the bad guys are going
to go to earth because they know that
none of the good guys are going to go
there because it's a rule it's an arrest
of all offense to now go to earth but
the motivation behind Jason and the
Galactic Council is not unreasonable
historically speaking all the crappiest
things to happen in the universe have
happened because of earth when it came
to the original crease World War these
two races that have been boring for
millions of years when their conflict
almost impacted earth Charles Xavier
Iron Man Doctor Strange black bolt of
the Inhumans you know a handful of
others Reed Richards they formed the
Illuminati they raced off to to the to
the scrolls and said do not bring your
conflicts here keep your conflicts there
you know the Infinity Gauntlet has been
accessed by people on earth Danos has
routinely invaded earth looking for the
cosmic you but in fact the Infinity
stones are currently on earth at the
time this story is being written No
maybe they're destroyed I don't remember
I don't remember if Hickman basically
wrote that they were destroyed by this
point in time Captain America tried to
use it during the incursions and try to
push a universe away and it resulted in
the infinity gems exploding it's insane
it's so amazing it was one hell of a way
to start his run on Avengers and new
Avengers which we'll cover next year as
part of our whole cosmic Marvel
landscape everything that goes on in the
Marvel cosmos between infinity war 1 and
infinity war 2 but nonetheless there's
all kinds of crazy scenarios that have
taken place here Galactus has routinely
tried to invade the earth and has
constantly been rebuked and so it's half
fear and half concern in a sense that if
there are beings on earth like Franklin
Richards who can warp the universe you
know there's guys like the molecule man
who can warp the multiverse then earth
is a very dangerous place at the same
time the earth has to be maintained it
has to be kept contained because in the
eyes of these different races than in
the eyes adjacent a smart acts earth is
home to basically children
people with an insane amount of power
but the lack of responsibility and the
inability to know how much is out there
and what is out there waiting for them
within the universe so again it's really
kind of cool to see this discussion but
the fact remains coming into the joining
of iron man in the guardians of the
galaxy again this really all comes out
of long way down now long way down was
basically Matt Fraction kind of bringing
an end to the iron man landscape to a
degree basically bring it into one era
and then allowing Karen Gillan to start
the next the long way down was largely a
great big huge campaign by like the
Mandarin and I really want to cover that
somewhere along the line but it was
basically Tony Stark faking his death
James Rhodes taking up the role of iron
man all his employ to basically defeat
the Mandarin and Ezekiel Stane operating
as you know of course the newest war
monger I think it was her Iron Monger
but the fact remains that Tony Stark
essentially engineered all these things
to basically lead to the downfall of
these guys but the problem is that like
some of his armors were being taken and
his role within the Marvel landscape was
being questioned due to the fact that he
was tricking people into believing that
he's drunk and so because of all these
major image issues of you know formation
of stark resilient different things like
that
he basically walked away from the mantle
of iron man on earth and went to space
to take time for himself now again this
was just segwaying from one thing into
another it was a way for Ironman to
basically just kind of explore to see
what all Marvel could do for this
character especially with the idea that
guardians of the galaxy was right down
the line Iron Man being as popular as he
is raising the profile of the guardians
made sense if they were going to take
the most popular characters from the
Cinematic Universe and then throw him
onto the team and the comic so again it
made perfect sense in terms of how it
worked but in the middle of all this
there's effectively a of a dune warship
just making its way towards Earth now of
course with Tony Stark doing what he can
to stop it he's met by the Guardians and
this again just shows kind of how they
work together how they all function but
it's also a new introduction to fans of
the guardians who see how it is they all
come together and of course the Brutes
basically the powerhouse rocket as the
demolitions expert Drax the destroyer
just wreck stuff and Gamora is very
stealthy and very very capable in terms
of an assassin of course Peter quill
basically being the one that runs the
whole show but that's not your main fear
that where the Badoon warship is
completely obliterated we see this
instance word Groot is basically
destroyed in his entirety and reduced
down to a single shard and so again in
the first guardians movie when when
groots was basically destroyed and then
they had him there's a little piece of
wood that he began to grow back from
there was precedent for this it wasn't
something that was completely unheard of
it wasn't something out of the ordinary
it'd already been established by the
time by the time the goddess of the
galaxy movie came out
now with the Badoon launching a
secondary ship to continue its campaign
of you know attacking earth and trying
to eliminate earth it's kind of cool to
see how the Guardians worked here so
well because of the fact that Bendis had
to find a way to give us consequence to
make the events impactful while at the
same time show us what the Guardians
were capable of and of course an attack
on earth always really works in that
scenario but it's not heavy-handed
it's not over-the-top it's not at the
guardians are facing off against a
thousand Badoon warships they would
never be able to pull that off what the
end up doing is just kind of going
against one but it's cool because
they're isolated to themselves to a
degree in the sense that the entire like
all the communications to the immediate
area have been cut off now there's a
little bit of fudging the you know kind
of cooking the books and fudging the
numbers here in the sense that Venice is
really just kind of asking us to believe
that the Avengers would be completely
unaware of the fact that there's a
warship invading earth and attacking
London now we don't know exactly what it
is is happening at the time we're kind
of left to believe that maybe the events
of infinity or maybe the events of you
know some other campaign is taking place
those are guys who don't know during the
events of infinity the Avengers were off
fighting against the the builders the
creators of the universe and Marvel
Comics but the other half of this is so
with the guardians so again this doesn't
really seem to fit in with that little
bit of a little bit of context but
regardless of what's happening
regardless of you know what's taking
place the fact remains that we're just
kind of left to believe that the
guardians are on their own now of course
the reason why again the Avengers or the
x-men are none of those groups can be
contacted is because the fact that all
communications are out but then the
questions ask is there other any
localized heroes is there anybody here
in Britain that can help to face off
against this threat now of course
Ironman chimes in and says they're the
captain Britain and when they ask is he
any good
like Iron Man's like not really because
Captain Britain does kind of suck he's
not a very good here I was going to piss
off all the Captain Britain fans but I'm
sorry if Captain Britain was popular or
in any way capable of doing anything he
would be in a lot more books than he is
right now so the fact remains that we
switch over to about six weeks ago in
the negative zone now remember because
of the fact of the negative zone can
only be accessible through portals it's
basically like stepping into a closet
closing the door and then having a
conversation if no one knows you're
there no one can overhear you and so
it's big
hiding away from the universe and more
or less meeting in secret now again this
is not unheard of bidness has done this
before the Illuminati did this time and
time again whenever the Illuminati met
and Charles Xavier was with them even if
they were in Wakanda they were hidden
away Charles Xavier would still use his
telepathy to make sure that no one knew
they were there and so again it's very
much this kind of repeating pattern of
been describing something that he's
already created rolling it over and then
more or less reworking it so again it
works pretty well but what Jason the
smart axe does here when he's speaking
to the leader of Asgard when he's
speaking to all mother when he's
speaking to the supreme intelligence
when he's talking to the medulla and the
brood and so on and so forth the entire
events being overseen by the watcher
just because of the fact that is such a
significant moment but Jason again
basically makes the case that the earth
has been home to conflicts time and time
again Franklin Richards the molecule man
the secret Wars event events like Thanos
invading the planet Earth Galactus being
being subdued time and time again
Franklin Richards
resurrecting Galactus the idea of Reed
Richards and so on being in possession
of the ultimate nullifier which has the
power to obliterate the universe in its
entirety the earth is viewed as a very
dangerous place and so because of this
the idea is that with the earth being so
dangerous it needs to be kept off limits
now almost immediately after this
designation is this claim is made by by
Jason the smart acts all mother turns in
and says that's ridiculous now a little
bit of a discussion here when it comes
to when it comes to all mother and the
idea of Asgard essentially what had
happened is that during the events of
siege when Norman Osborn was director of
shield he had launched a campaign
against Asgard which at the time had
been recreated by Thor following the
events of Ragnarok and so Asgard was
housed in Roxton Oklahoma hovering above
the ground with Norman Osborn declaring
war against Asgard with the intention of
conquering it and basically solidifying
the United States under his control
I have Guard itself was totally
destroyed now this led to Tony Stark
basically recreating Asgard and having
it dubbed as guardian it was really just
kind of the saying where Asgard was this
placement had different kind of rockets
and so on attached to it but all mother
became the ruler of Asgard during the
events of fear itself and the reason why
is because fear itself dealt with the
unknown brother of Odin who was believed
to be the rightful ruler of Asgard and
he was called a serpent and led to all
different kinds of crazy stuff again
we're going to cover that but in the
midst of this in order for
everybody to fight against against the
serpent without any massive loss of life
among you know the planet Earth Odin
basically recreated Asgard in the
traditional sense in the realm of Asgard
and then took everybody over there had
this massive battle once the serpent was
basically defeated everybody was booted
out and Odin stayed there by himself and
so that's why if you guys are going
through and you're reading about you
know all-new all-different Thor so on a
sword you have Asgard and then you have
Asgardian or really have like old Asgard
is what it's called now and then you
have Asgardian that's why you have two
different versions of Asgard basically
but again we'll go more in depth into
that once we get to like fear itself and
all that kind of good stuff because that
is one hell of a story absolutely love
fear itself is such a great line of
stories like juggernaut gets a hammer
like like all these are guys like
juggernaut looks amazing when he's got
like the ham yeah when he's got his own
hammer it's really really cool but the
fact remains here that that all motive
basically says look earth is one of the
nine realms
it is part of my land as part of my
territory if you invoke yourself in an
act of war there will be hell to pay
and so again what Jason says is look
we're not invoking war we're making it
off limits we're not going to attack it
now of course this leads into the attack
by the badoon themselves which is kind
of crazy in and of itself in the sense
of they more or less appear to have gone
rogue but showing back to the present
day we pick up with iron man we pick up
with star-lord and these different guys
and the idea that they're all being held
by JSON of spartax now the fact that
Jason is basically taking a son prisoner
is a massive blow to morale for those
who will find out about it but with
Jason basically appearing to the
Galactic Council in the modern day and
chastising the badoon what just does is
it puts him in the light of being
extremely arrogant it puts him in the
light of talking down to people with
whom he has no business talking down to
his arrogance is effectively getting in
the way of his ability to function
correctly and the reason why is because
smart acts is not the create smart acts
is not the scrolls or not the Badoon or
not the she arc they're not nearly that
old and they're not merely that strong
they're capable but the the smart acts
would not be able to withstand a full
onslaught by the Shiar Empire they would
not be able to withstand a full
onslaught by the Kree or the scrolls or
the brood and especially the Badoon
there's no way they could withstand that
whole thing and so because of that all
these individuals basically begin
looking at Jason and saying hey maybe
it's time for him to stop being king you
know maybe it's time for him
be done with all his living and so
because of that we basically jump back
to the smart acts worship with group
regrowing a group coming back to his
normal self now this is hilarious this
is really really cool because I was
reading this and I kept thinking of this
really funny moment so group goes into
the ship where where the guardians of
the galaxy are being held in stasis and
tries to free them but in the process
accidentally activates the the
elimination of life support meaning life
supports going to shutdown in like five
seconds and so in response he just
basically destroys them faceless tubes
and allows the audience to escape but I
thought it would have been hilarious if
they had just pretended to be dead and
group believed that he killed him I
thought it would have been hilarious I
would have laughed so hard I mean it
would have been mean but it would have
been funny it would have been absolutely
hysterical so the fact remains here with
the Guardians making their escape at the
hands of brute basically going and
rescuing Ironman from here we basically
pick up a star-lord accessing the
entirety of the communications grid for
smart acts and essentially creating this
really really cool message and this is
the reason why star-lord why Peter is so
cool it's because he accesses the whole
communications grid everybody on smart
acts sees what is he saying he's like
look I am the son of Emperor Jason of
smart acts he had me arrested
because I was trying to protect the
earth when he basically left the earth
defenseless now if he's going to arrest
me for doing the right thing imagine
what he'll do to you if you do not
follow his orders if you don't do what
he tells you to basically it makes it
look like Jason's lost his mind it makes
it look like you know he's a
legitimately evil guy people begin
turning their backs on him and
questioning him as a leader and like any
Emperor he's only in charged so long as
people allow him to be in charge because
of what good is an emperor that can't
control his own arm of what good is an
emperor against a society of six hundred
million people who won't follow his
orders and who overthrow his police and
overthrow his soldiers then he's just a
guy and so because of that you know he's
no more in charge than the little rock
on the side of the road so again it's
kind of a funny scenario in terms of
what direction things go in but again
this really just kind of ends the first
story arc Ironman joining the they got
into the galaxy and so on but if you
guys are new here to comment to explain
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah
I will catch you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]